Nathan Drake is a master thief but
sometimes he's so good he slips right
past release dates if you're
anticipating uncharted for his march for
lease I'm sorry to say you left await an
extra month it's a lot to digest you
know a thief's end will release on April
26th in the US and on April 27th in the
UK and europe according to directors
Neil druckmann at Bruce Straley naughty
dog needs more time to polish the game
to meet their vision in a post on the
PlayStation Blog the duo said this is
our largest uncharted and the team has
been working incredibly hard to meet the
challenge of closing out the game's
development in a timely manner however
as we started to approach our final
deadlines and started wrapping up the
game's levels we realize that several
key sequences needed extra resources to
bring them to the finish line all told
this delay means naughty dog has a
chance to give the final uncharted game
a few more passes before it gets pressed
to disk when uncharted 4 does release
you can pick up the special edition or
liver thalia collector's edition if you
really want to show off your uncharted
love in the meantime stay tuned to
gamespot for all the latest on Nathan
Drake's outings